so people keep writing to me and saying  david sir when are you going to talk  about dinesh d'souza's  movie i can't even call it a documentary  because it's  just audio and video it's not very  documentary in nature it's his movie  2000 mules  here's the deal with the movie 2000  mules  the movie argues  using mobile phone geolocation data of  limited accuracy  that a whole bunch of people that he  calls ballot mules  were trafficking  massive dumps of ballots in a huge fraud  scheme in the 2020 election  unfortunately there's no real evidence  the geolocation data is of limited  accuracy  the locations of individuals relative to  ballot boxes is circumstantial and  there's no actual proof of any of it i  just saved you what is it two hours and  20 bucks